bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france je disais la
marque revient au monde d'avant est ce
que c'est une bonne chose d'abord
le danemark que vous l'avez très bien
expliquée avec trois critères le fait
que ce omicron soit invariants quand
même beaucoup moins sévères que les
précédents le fait que la grande
majorité à 84% de la population danoise
est vacciné est pratiquement l'ensemble
des personnes vulnérables des segments
vulnérables de cette population et puis
la capacité hospitalière qui fait face
aujourd'hui qui pourrait encore faire
davantage face qui est moins affecté
qu'elle ne l'avait été pendant les
premières vagues donc cessons ces
critères qui font que le gouvernement
décide parce qu'il y a une forme
d'embellie
d'accalmie prévu le danemark est très
près de son pic un tout petit peu en
retard par rapport à la france peut être
aussi le danemark et la victime
aujourd'hui d'un sou variant de omicron
le béa 2 qui prolonge un petit peu cette
vague mais la vague est en train de
d'arriver à son pic et devrait la décrue
devrait survenir bientôt et donc on peut
dire que les danois veulent profiter de
l'accalmie sans savoir plus que les
autres combien de temps elle durera
justement vous l'avez apprécié il ya
deux arguments avancés on l'a dit la
vaccination la moindre sévérité de
mikron est ce que c'est une stratégie
qui est adaptée face à la situation que
l'on connaît actuellement
alors certes c'est un peu précoce de
prendre ce type de mesure dans la mesure
où la décrue n'a pas encore vraiment
commencé on ne sait pas on voit par
exemple que les britanniques ont eu
aussi des allègements de leurs de leurs
mesures sanitaires et la décrue qui
était très rapide très prononcé depuis
quelques semaines s'est arrêté
maintenant il ya une sorte de plateau
donc il est possible que ce ces
allègements très tôt dans la cour de la
vague épidémique prolonge
le niveau de contamination et
malheureusement aussi les
hospitalisations les formes graves et la
vague de mortalité à venir donc je ne
sais pas si c'est raisonnable de lever
toutes les mesures comme le font les
danois ou les britanniques de façon si
rapide alors même que la décrue n'est
pas suffisamment prononcée ailleurs par
exemple en france c'est ce n'est pas
encore tout à fait le cas on le voit
bien pensé qu' on va suivre le mouvement
avec d'autres pays européens
alors je pense en effet que les pays ont
compris les mouvements compris qu' il
fallait faire preuve de beaucoup
d'agilité dans cette pandémie lorsque
l'accalmie arrive personne n'est capable
de dire combien de temps elle durera
peut pas dire aujourd'hui la pandémie
est finie on peut juste dire une
accalmie est en train de se profiler
profitons-en et ça je pense que c'est
tout à fait concevable
surtout avec un virus qui n'est pas
aussi violent que c'est traîner ses
soeurs ce qu'il faut c'est définir les
critères de cette accalmie vous savez
les français avaient dit à partir de
5000 cas par jour au dessous de 5000 cas
par jour c'était peut-être dans les
anciennes vague mais on peut estimer
qu'on est en décrue en étant accalmie je
pense que d'avoir de ce genre de
critères seraient assez
opérationnel aujourd'hui et on pourrait
en effet se dire que lorsque l'on est à
un niveau très faible de circulation du
virus alors tous ces gestes barrières
tous et toutes ces mesures ne sont pas
nécessaires mais aujourd'hui où le virus
circule très activement sur le
territoire français en particulier mais
sur beaucoup de territoires européens il
me semble que c'est trop tôt de lâcher
toutes les mesures il me semble que le
masque il me semble que
le télétravail certain nombre de mesures
peuvent encore permettre de réduire les
contaminations et d'éviter un
engorgement des hôpitaux ou en tout cas
une augmentation de la saturation des
hôpitaux les hôpitaux vivent depuis deux
ans en tension permanente je crois que
ce n'est pas forcément une très bonne
mesure que de vouloir encore saturé
augmenter la tension dans les hôpitaux
alors on se souvient que les pays
nordiques avaient gérer l'épidémie
autrement c'était au début de cette
crise sanitaire là encore on le voit le
danemark se démarque par sa souplesse
c'est un argument d'ailleurs qui est
souvent repris par les anti-pacs ce
vaccinale notamment en france comment
vous vous l'expliquer on nous dit
souvent regarder ce qui se passe dans
les pays nordiques alors c'est vrai que
les pays nordiques et je prendrai comme
exemple danemark mais aussi la finlande
aussi la norvège ont toujours fait
preuve de beaucoup d'agilité mais n'en
déplaise aux anti passe où il se trouve
que le danemark avait quand même été le
premier pays à confiner strictement le
pays en
2020 en mars 2001 juste après l'italie
le danemark n'a pas attendu d'avoir plus
d'un mort pour décider le confinement de
son pays sert qui n'ont pas confiné
parce que le pays était au bord de la
saturation des hôpitaux ils ont confiné
par cette agilité qui va dans les deux
sens c'est à dire que on est les
premiers à confiner le danemark a été
les premiers à mettre le pass sanitaire
ça s'appelait le corona passe au
danemark mais ça a été les premiers à
mettre le corona passe en avril dernier
donc ils n'ont pas attendu ils ont agi
très précocement mais après ils peuvent
se permettre d'agir très précocement
aussi dans l'autre sens pour retirer ces
mesures et on voit aussi une très grande
confiance un grand degré de confiance
entre la population et ses autorités
sanitaires et ses experts donc on a
aussi un bon très bon niveau de
confiance en france ou en suisse mais on
voit que les pays nordiques ont cette
habitude d'une grande responsabilité
individuelle dans la prise en charge de
des problèmes de santé et d'une
confiance dans les autorités qui
prennent assez peu de mesures strictes
et qui incite la population à s'auto
confiné ou à prendre des mesures de type
télétravail par exemple merci beaucoup à
vous pour cet éclairage antoine flahault
épidémiologiste
directeur de l'institut de santé globale
de l'université de genève